je le vois pas du tout comme ça au
contraire je pense que parcours sud est
un système profondément et
méritocratique et que c'est un système
assez sélectif et que loin de loin
d'aplanir les niveaux y creusent les
inégalités parcours stups est assez
floue dans les critères que qu'il tient
c'est tellement flou on sait jamais si
le lycée d'origine va être important si
la ville doit être importante
tout était tout est un peu flou et donc
on a du mal à savoir nous même si notre
lycée va avoir une important sur notre
sélection et à un certain degré
d'inégalité qui sont faites par parcours
su par décret notamment sur les lycées
d'origine oui il ya un flou qui est
avérée mais de manière générale en fait
par coups reçus pour nous c'est un
système très opaque
ce conte ce qu'on attend c'est qu'en
plus d'être sélectif parcours super
parcours super va laisser à chaque
établissement d'accueil la possibilité
de choisir ses critères et ça ça crée
une inégalité entre les candidats parce
que les candidats suivants l'université
dans laquelle ils vont postuler bas ils
vont se retrouver ils vont se retrouver
avec des critères différents pour une
même pour une même même pour une même
formation
pour moi il ya deux sortes les du
supérieur et à des études sélective et
des études longues sélective sont
l'équipe la fac l'université en effet
que je rejoins sur le logement
elles doivent être accessibles ces
études doivent être accessibles à tout
le monde c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas
19 de moyenne c'est pas parce qu'on a un
but c'est parce qu'on n'a pas un
bulletin exceptionnel l'élève n'est pas
capable d'aller dans une grande école
qui n'est pas capable de suivre un
parcours sélectif
je pense qu'on peut aller plus loin en
analysant les doses analysant les
engagements des élèves
les activités extérieures autant en
sculpture est l engagement citoyen on a
chacun des engagements qu'ils devraient
pour moi être valorisés dans parcours
sup valoriser pour la sélection pour le
supérieur
et c'est plus un travail de de faire
développer des faire évoluer ses
commentaires ses critères de sélection
avec les engagements avec le parcours de
l'élève avec le dossier de l'élève
moi je pense que mon camarade ne va pas
assez loin
clairement le la formation centrale dans
dans l'enseignement supérieur français
c'est l'université aujourd'hui ce qui
n'est pas normal c'est qu'il y ait de la
sélection l'université et ce qui n'est
pas normal c'est qu'il n'est pas assez
de moyens à l'université parce qu'en fin
de compte sept sélections opérées par sa
part parcourt succès qu'un symptôme de
sélection de 2,2 ce manque de moyens
fondamentalement pour moi le problème
c'est l'inégalité d'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur qui à mon sens
est un service public et qui doit être à
laisser accessible à tous en particulier
l'université publique
[Musique]
stade sup a été a été pensé à mon sens
un bain consulat était censé comme un
site a été pensé comme un système
parasites qui nuit au service public de
l'enseignement supérieur au profit de
l'enseignement privé
on a vu des plaines on avait eu cette
plateforme peu intuitif voire austère et
qui est relativement beau mais on a vu
des bugs que par le passé qui provoque
naturellement un stress chez les lycéens
avec ces phases d'attenté ces phases des
essais libres
ces phases ces différentes face à ces
listes d'attentes et tout ça s'est
inscrit à mon sens un dans une politique
néolibérale de jean michel blanquer rhin
qui n'a toujours que connut le privé et
qui a été tardivement par tes dents donc
dans dans l'enseignement public est à
mon sens ce parcours sud n'a pas d'autre
intérêt aujourd'hui que de nuire que de
nuire à l'enseignement supérieur et à
mon sens on devrait mettre fin à cette
aberration et trouver un système plus
juste où l'investissement massif dans
l'enseignement serait l'une des clés de
voûte
je pense que sur cette question-là
parcours si tout n'est pas complètement
à jeter il ya beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent être améliorées on l'a dit ce
soir je pense que par pur sucre n'est
pas un problème isolé parcours sup c'est
un peu la conséquence de tout le
fonctionnement général de l'enseignement
supérieur en france qui demande
forcément plus de moyens voilà qui
nécessite plus de moyens dans les
prochaines années
surtout quand le nombre d'élèves ne fait
que s'accroître depuis plusieurs années